what harm does your attempt to shut down
what words you regard as harmful
what's that likely to produce for harm
well none it's like oh really so you
haven't thought that part of it through
at all and you're going to be the
arbiter of what's harmful and what's not
and there's no danger in that either is
there
so
that's a good way to
deal with that sort of thing i agree of
course another thing that the a lot of
the time people people don't see is they
think you know we could impose on
people's speech we can tell them how to
behave various ways but they don't think
that that's an instrument that could be
abused in all sorts of ways so if you
mandate speech on one thing one day it's
going to be mandated on other things the
next day and in general i think with any
form of cohesive coercive principle you
need to think what's going to happen in
the hands of somebody wicked and you
know tyrannical that's how we should
think about about these things not only
in university but in politics more
generally
[Music]
hello everybody i'm speaking today with
dr james orr and dr eric achmed both
professors at cambridge university
dr orr is in the faculty of divinity and
specializes in the philosophy of
religion
dr ahmed is in the faculty of philosophy
and specializes in the study of
decision-making in the face of
uncertainty which is a particular
interest of mine and is a leading expert
on the philosopher ludwig wittgenstein's
later work including his writing on
religions i recently released a
discussion with dr orr and dr nigel
bigger which was well received and
about religious issues and philosophical
issues in general so more academic
discussion but we decided to follow that
up with a talk about some events that
occurred in march 2019
when i was disinvited to cambridge after
being invited we're going to talk about
what happened since since i'm returning
i'm going to be going to cambridge and
to oxford for the last two weeks of
november so we're going to talk about
how that came about
about the state of free speech
at the academy in general and other
general issues
so i'll start by telling the story of
the disinvitation as i experienced it so
i was invited to cambridge
by some professors in the faculty of
divinity to
conduct a seminar or to take part in the
seminar on exodus which was to be a
follow-up to
my lectures on genesis which proved to
be somewhat surprisingly popular on
youtube and so
i thought i would delve into exodus with
some of the world's leading authorities
to sharpen myself up and then maybe
dive into
exodus as a lecture series
anyways we had that planned and then
it got cancelled because a photograph of
me
emerged
that was taken with this guy in new
zealand and
now that was taken during a meet and
greet after my
tour lecture so i went to 130 cities in
and afterwards at all of them i had my
picture taken with about a hundred
people
one by one or two by two sometimes with
families so about maybe 15 000 pictures
photographs
of which this was one and so i remember
this actually at new zealand
so this guy
came walking up to me and he sort of
stopped and he had this t-shirt on and
he looked at me sort of questioningly
and it was a t-shirt outlining his
criticisms of islam
of radical islam as he saw it and i
looked at it and i looked at him and
again he kind of looked questioning and
apologetic and then i thought well you
know that's your t-shirt mate and that's
up to you to wear that and so
you know i motioned them forward we had
our picture taken and i really didn't
think anything of it after that but
apparently many people did
and so
i was disinvited because of my repugnant
views which were hypothetically
indicated by the fact that i took one
picture out of 15 000 with this
gentleman wearing a
opinionated t-shirt and so that was
apparently justification for canceling
an intense academic endeavor aimed at
bringing
the work
in exodus to as broad a public
population as possible in the most
rigorous manner possible
and so that was quite
a shock i would say and
um you know it wasn't particularly
enjoyable to go through all that
so
well
that's turned around and now i'm invited
back and i'm going in november and so
how did james maybe you could start how
did that all come about do you think
like why did that happen and
why
has it been reversed
well thank you jordan and just listening
to you recount your your experiences of
beginning of march 2019 was it beginning
of 2019 is um
well it's it's it's
pretty pretty
moving to watch and difficult to hear
but um i just want to stress that with
all that in the background it's
incredibly gracious of you to have
accepted my invitation to to come over
to cambridge um i'm thrilled about it
i'm thrilled about it it's so it's not a
favor in any sense i'm it's a great
university and i'm i think it's an
unbelievable privilege to go there and
to go to oxford so
i'm absolutely thrilled about it
well if i may say so i think it's a it's
a testament to your character and to
your resilience and capacity for
forbearance and forgiveness that you've
that you've accepted the invitation and
i just by way of encouragement i i want
to say that the reaction to the news of
of your visit from colleagues and from
students in the university beyond the
university from members of the general
public has been overwhelmingly positive
i i it's been difficult to respond to
all the supportive messages i've
received in in the wake of the
announcement
um and i just think it's obvious from
just from the reaction to the kinds of
questions that we were exploring
on on your podcast a few weeks ago that
there's a huge appetite among people for
the kinds of questions that that were
going that we were exploring in that
conversation and that we're planning to
explore in research seminars and and
talks with with colleagues and and
students here
uh in november and as i said to my uh
colleagues uh who who i think are
excited about your visit i've had almost
no no word of criticism at all uh from
colleagues in the faculty or from
students and the faculty um i think
there's a recognition that that you
would be you're going to be a perfect
interlocutor for all sorts of people
here particularly on quests those of us
who work in for those of us who work in
theology and and religion
you've encouraged uh lots of young
people to to take sacred text seriously
to think about how you read to read
ancient difficult texts about the
the meaning and value of religion and
society today so
um
you know i know that was a difficult
time for you and
um i'd not actually been appointed to my
post back then or think i maybe i had
been appointed just a few weeks before
all that happened but so i wasn't privy
to the kind of inner workings of the the
decision making and so on and um
i think what i can say is that it was a
relative a very very small number of
people who were
concerned or showing
strong resistance to to to your coming
um i think this is something that we can
talk about later that the way in which
in
these big universities a relatively
small number of determined
ideologue ideologically
driven students it's often students but
but also colleagues who will
who will buckle in the face of student
resistance uh ca
the the the the capacity they have to
project the idea that their view is a
dominant orthodoxy and i think the
mechanics of how that happens is is a
very interesting one and
and and the the gap between the sort of
asymmetry between those two
two positions what seems what is
actually a a a a minority view and then
this this
impression that that it's it's a it's a
very uh uh that it's an orthodoxy as i
said uh was laid there in the in the
events that that followed which um
uh really were prompted by
what arif decided to do uh in response
to the university announcing that it was
going to set out at
uh uh
yeah well it's very
it's very interesting and strange that
i could be sufficiently reprehensible to
be banned from the university
you know three years ago and i haven't
changed i don't think
and yet when i'm reinvited that the
overwhelming
response that you've received so far is
positive that's very peculiar and so
and and worth delving into i think um
and and and dr ahmed you were you played
a role in now as i understand it the
policies of the university with regards
to inviting speakers have actually been
changed and the mechanics of that are
worth delving into too just so maybe you
could tell us the story about how that
happened and why and how you got
involved yeah thank you um uh before i
start with that jordan i just want to
say
that we're first of all really positive
and looking forward to your to your
visit and like james i've had a lot of
positive
comments about it um but also that we as
a university should be very grateful to
james all because he was the one who had
the vision and the initiative to
re-extend the invitation um and it's
great that he's that he's done that um
now in terms of what happened um as you
say there was this what i regard as
outrageous um disinvitation of you in
the spring of 2019 so as you know what
happened was was you were invited you
accepted the invitation
and
you were then disinvited and as i recall
not even told that you've been
disinvited you found out yeah that was
one of the funny things yeah you found
out on twitter they didn't even have a i
mean it was not only discourteous but
worse than discourteous it was it was
cowardly i thought um
well if you had to make a case for the
people who disinvited me like what is it
what do you think it was that they were
trying to stop exactly i mean it's worth
investigating the motives and the belief
as well as then we can talk about to
some degree the fact that it seems to be
a minority view
well my feeling is that it's it's
related to the things that james was
saying that the university authorities
or those who are responsible for this
decision um have been frightened by by a
group of highly committed ideologues who
gave the impression that this was a
general university view that there was
outrage about about your position in
fact i didn't think that's true and in
any case being photographed next to
someone um doesn't imply anything about
your position at all and that was one of
the most outrageous things with the
statement by the university at the time
which they called as i recall
endorsement by association as though
simply standing next to someone who's
who's wearing clothes that expresses
views implies that you have those views
yourself um that argument was so bad it
must have been a pretext and i think it
was a pretext it was a pretext for a
kind of a kind of fear of a mob um so
what do you think they were afraid of so
let's say it wasn't the fact that i got
had my picture taken with this character
who was wearing this t-shirt it was
something else
that they didn't want me to do i suppose
or be what do you think that was exactly
do you have any sense of that yeah i
think ultimately they were they pro they
probably feared protests they feared
reputational damage they feared a sense
that all the students would think that
cambridge was was
was enabling someone who these people
regarded as as unacceptable um those are
the things they fear but frankly
if you're an academic the one thing
the one thing that is your job is not to
care what the mob thinks it's not to
care you know who's going to be upset or
frightened by the people you like you
better invite people because they can
speak the truth and you can have
discussion which leads to mutual you
know understanding and advancement of
knowledge so i think yes well and we
should hope we should all devoutly hope
that an institution as august and as
remarkable as cambridge
would be a model
for courage in such matters instead of
being cowed by
a
loud ideologically possessed minority
because you know you might think well if
cambridge university can't withstand
this
then who the hell can
and that's a real that's a serious
question and and
these things have to be examined
seriously i mean
it's
we need institutions that we can respect
and that
and that hold up the standards that have
made them what they are and if they fold
well how can you expect
normal people say not to be cowed and
intimidated by the same tactics
absolutely
actually there were two other episodes
on my mind one of which sort of
confirmed my theory about what was
happening in your case the other of
which suggested different sorts of
motivations so one of them was a case
that occurred around the same time as
yours which was a case of a research
fellow at sid edmonds college here in
cambridge
who was doing research he's a
sociologist a very well-known
respectable sociologist he had workers
work profiled in the economist and top
journals um he was fired because there
was a again there was a mob protesting
about his associations conferences he'd
been to journals that he published in
which other people that they found
distasteful and published and so on
again donald said nothing illegal that
was one case which again i think
illustrates the sorts of pressures that
i think will be brought to bear what
were the topics for that
the topic is race and intelligence yes
yes yes well the intelligence literature
is
is rough
that's for sure i mean the whole the
whole thing is was so chilling because
it was it was decided by an inquiry that
was kept secret nobody's going to know
what the evidence was in this inquiry um
so the whole thing was was terrifying um
the other case was slightly different so
there was another case that concerned me
which was a case where it was a it was
an event for the palestinian society
where there was a chair from that
society
which the university threatened to shut
down because they thought they were
worried that the chair might be an
extremist or something she wasn't at all
she was a respectful respectable
academic from soas um and the university
imposed its own its own chair on that
now that was slightly different because
that was responding to another another
threat of free speech which is the
government's legislation on prevent and
anti-terrorism um but those three events
were sort of coalescing in my mind
around the time that i tried to change
the um
change the university's free speech
policy
okay so what did so let's talk about the
change in the free speech policy what
what changes did you propose and then it
took a couple of years as i understand
to really get this
through and i also understand from james
that
it wasn't that easy to get people to
speak in favor of your proposal but that
it was passed and we need to go into
that by an overwhelming majority of the
people who were concerned and able to
legislate such things so to speak for
the university
yeah so i can take you through that what
happened was it was this was around
actually march 2020 so about a year
after your your case and
the university had decided that it was
going to put through a new freedom of
speech policy um
uh this is obviously at a time when
everyone had had other things on their
mind at least in britain in march 2020.
they didn't offer a vote on it they just
wanted to put it straight through and it
was a policy which i found concerning
especially in life of these incidents um
one part of it was that it mandates said
that we have right free speech but we
must always exercise respect for other
people's identities
and opinions now that might seem
innocuous um
uh but of course the word respect being
so vague
it doesn't seem innocuous to me
i mean it seems terrible because it just
it just removes the first part of
protection for free speech i mean if you
have to be cautious about other people's
opinions
much less their identity well we should
reverse that their identity much less
their opinions is well who decides when
that's respectful and what yeah yeah
it's just weasel words that exactly and
the bit about identities i bet they had
you in mind when they were saying that
actually um uh
but whenever anyone says i believe in
free speech but that's a good sign to me
that they don't believe in free speech
and that was the impression that this
policy gave off other parts of the
policy um which may not have been
directly explicitly new but which
certainly brought you and those other
cases for instance the palestinian
society to mind
were rules which said that the
university could stop speaker events if
they thought they would threaten the
welfare of students and then there's no
wealth welfare is defined to get
undefined and could be interpreted
broadly um and indeed allow the
university to stop events under pretty
much any circumstances that they like
speaker events for instance
so those were that was the proposed
policy in march 2020 so why did that why
did that bother you so much i mean
you're pretty young and and and starting
your academic career in many ways
maybe i'm wrong about that but
you know it's a hell of a thing to take
on and it's not without its risks and
i'm always curious about people's
motives it's like there's lots of
professors at cambridge why why do you
think this was your problem
well you flattened me if i'd be young
but but
i will say that i guess there were two
things one of them was philosophical one
was more to do with the nature of the
job so philosophically speaking my basic
philosophical position is what you might
call classical liberal so my basic value
is individual liberty um
and uh you know i would in terms of what
would i do my political engagement um
even my professional engagement to some
extent you know that's the ultimate most
important important value so for me it
really touched a nerve
it touched something that was the core
of my identity if you want to use that
that um appalling word
um the other aspect which i said was
professional was simply to do something
i alluded to earlier which was what is
this job for it's part of your duty as
an academic i would have thought you
know academics are normally cautious as
they should be but the one thing that
they shouldn't be cautious about is
defending the ultimate
purpose of the academy and that cannot
be um
pursued without free speech
and without the ability to question
freely um beliefs that are held by the
majority also beliefs that are held by
minorities and without worrying about
who you're going to offend who's going
to be hurt by your words especially in a
in a subject like philosophy and ideas
in a subject like yours and certainly in
a subject like james's you know you
can't have free discussion if every time
you talk about something you're
frightened that you're going to offend
the other person and then they might
report you and you might get in trouble
i can't do my job i don't expect james
can i do things but you can if you if
discussion is curtailed in that way so
no scientists can because that freedom
of inquiry and the freedom to upset
traditional truths let's say well in
some in a more really fundamental sense
that's what science is all about and
as a
let's say a creative scientist you're
always working against
what's established because otherwise
what you discovered wouldn't be new and
you're always going to be facing people
who are upset for one reason or another
by your hypothesis and your research so
it's it's it's not it's not a side uh
issue here it's it's crucial to the
academy as such yeah absolutely it's
it's absolutely but that still doesn't
explain why you made it your problem say
when so many people were perfectly
willing to remain silent well one thing
i would say was that i was like i was
slightly surprised um when i wrote so
after after the university's policy came
out
there was a discussion what's called the
discussion in cambridge university
really means that you write a paper and
it's it's published in the university
magazine um and so i sent a short paper
off proposing some changes to these
policies and stating my objections and i
had expected this being cambridge
university that many other people would
do the same um because i didn't think i
was alone in being concerned about this
um
uh nobody else did so i was that was the
first point in which i realized so there
was no there was no real brave real
markup because i had expected at that
point that a lot of people a lot of
other people would be would be jumping
in um
nobody did so that was the point at
which i realized that i was perhaps more
isolated
than i'd expected um
to go back to your question about
motivation i don't know what more i can
tell you i mean these are things that
matter to me i don't really care if
anyone else is doing it or not and did
you face any trouble so you voiced your
opinion and you wanted to modify this
this document which had let's say
politically correct underpinnings and
did it cause grief for you were people
outraged by what you said or or did
things proceed as a matter of course
well it was interesting so some people
uh some people wrote to me in fact quite
a few people wrote to me at the time
saying that they agreed with with my
concerns um which should of made it even
more surprising that nobody had actually
said so in public um some people wrote
to me saying they agree with my concerns
that weren't willing to to say anything
in public um
uh james was was as always was
brilliantly helpful james has always
been really supportive and james has
been publicly supportive
throughout this process but it's because
there have been a few courageous people
like james and a few others you know in
cambridge at that stage that was
definitely a big a big help um so there
was some support i also had people
warning me so i had people saying
you know you might get you know you
might get some kind of disciplinary
procedure you might get some kind of
investigation i didn't expect anything
at that stage then indeed nothing
happened um to me at that stage and i'm
pleased to say there'd be no
investigations or anything out of me of
me since um
so that's really interesting in two ways
isn't it because
it shows you how loath people are to do
this because they're afraid and we
shouldn't make light of that because
this is actually no fun
you know if if you do something like
this and it explodes in your face like
it it probably took me
oh it took me a long time to recover
from the disinvitation especially the
way it was handled and my health and my
wife's health were extremely compromised
at the time and so it came at a
a particularly bad time maybe we had
just received news that she probably had
terminal cancer and so this came on top
of that now luckily that she survived
thank god but
you know it was a harrowing time
and so i i see why people can be cowed
like this because
you know you don't know when this is
going to explode and when it's going to
tangle you up so deeply that while your
job's gone that's what happened to the
weinsteins for example at evergreen and
i mean
that was really that did them a
tremendous amount of damage they're
unbelievably resourceful and they got
back on their feet
and and you know they were a husband and
wife team so they had each other and
that was good but not everybody can do
that and you can get seriously taken out
if if something like this goes wrong
so
but then that ties into this issue we
discussed a bit earlier which is how a
small minority of you know people who
whose wrath knows no bounds in some
sense can be so dominant yeah
so it was it was it was in some ways a
calculated risk and i i can't imagine
how difficult that must have been for
you jordan it was it would you know it
must have been
horrific um
i mean one thing i saw happening in
cambridge not right not quite then but a
little bit later was the treatment
that was meted out to not an academic
but to a member of the university staff
so we have we have college porters in
cambridge and these are these people who
work at the colleges um uh often they're
they're sort of you know retired
policemen or military or something
really helpful they do all kinds of jobs
around the college students rely on them
the academics rely on them the ones in
my college brilliant
there was one at a college in cambridge
who was also a labour councillor
who who resigned on political brands
which was to do with his view about
about trans issues so he thought it was
you know there was there was emotion
about trans issues that he thought you
know threatened women's safety and so he
resigned on a point of principle and
that's his political activity that's his
right i could i could understand his
grants for doing that
the students at his college so these are
typically much more privileged people
than him students at his college formed
the mob to try to get this man sacked um
and this was this was you know this is a
much more privileged people they didn't
care about you know the consequences for
him um they just thought because he
diverted from their line of ideological
purity do you remember this case james
and james may now want to leave it
yeah
i do it it was thanks to a very brave
female undergraduate i think she was in
her even her second year she spoke out
uh wrote a public article about it a a
great courage i thought to herself and
she uh there was an awful lot of
resistance to her doing that but uh it
was remarkable uh she got in touch with
us i seem to remember and i can't
remember how the case was resolved
well i think the case the case in the
end was resolved positively um uh
but that's right sophie she was showing
stephanie watson she was brilliant um
she actually wrote an article in which
she said and i thought this is very
telling it just described the state of
the academy she said when i came to
cambridge i was expecting she said the
the motto of the royal society is don't
take anyone's word for it and she said
that's what she was expecting when i
come to cambridge i was expecting to
engage in rigorous discussion where all
of my cherished beliefs would be
challenged um you know allowed to come
away shaken and uncomfortable and i
would think for myself and i would be
forced to rethink everything with the
most important things in my life i think
she was actually studying psychology um
and then she said when i got here it
wasn't like that when i got here i felt
that that i was being coddled and there
were certain things that you couldn't
question certain things that you were
just made to feel outsider when you
questioned it was a really it was a
brilliant article um uh and really
telling because it was her own
experience of what what it's like for a
student now compared to what it was like
when i was when i was an undergraduate
you know many years ago
um
so that's an illustration of of how
things can go wrong and the sort of
things you know we were seeing around us
um in the sort of summer and then the
autumn of
2020. um james did you want to say
anything more about that point we can
talk more about about that
no i mean i think it was then wasn't it
june july 2020 i remember you came came
around for for lunch
around here we started talking about you
know who might be willing to uh sign in
public uh a support which was required
by the mechanisms of the um
all the kind of procedural mechanisms i
think we needed 25 names wasn't it um
and i think we could come up between us
we managed to come up with seven or
eight and then
and then it took us another
eight to ten weeks to
get past the 25 i think it was september
that we were starting to starting to
look promising and in fact i think in
the end we got
quite a few more than 25 for the three
amendments that that that rf was
proposing to introduce to kind of to to
take out the respect language and
replace it with okay so you needed
tolerance you needed those 25
to put the amendments forward that's
right yeah yeah okay so that would
indicate that some people were concerned
that that requirement for 25 rather than
just one person
but and it was hard to get 25. yeah it
was it's telling it's telling that
actually um i mean there might have been
two reasons why one reason why it might
have been because it was a trivial issue
and nobody cared about it who cares
quibbling about a few a few words
another reason which i suspect was you
know which turned out was with the more
likely explanation was that actually a
lot of people were afraid to sign
something in public so why do you think
it's not trivial and why do you think
that argument's invalid and
uh the reason i thought the argument was
it was invalid because the additional
evidence that i got after the vote
because the vote actually had a very
high a lot of people bothered to vote on
this
and they bothered to vote for that
change if it had been a trivial thing
nobody would have cared to vote um so
that was one bit of evidence the other
bit of evidence was the testimony of the
people who wrote to me or who i called
up at the time
and james may have got this as well you
know people who are saying look we
support this we can see what you're
doing and we can see why it's concerned
but i just don't want to get involved in
this kind of fight right now getting
involved in this is going to be too
difficult for me right now i'm up for
promotion right now you know yeah
i don't want to face all of these things
so yeah well you practice what you
become
you be sorry you become what you
practice and you know that's well and
this is something i learned as a
psychologist and i think maybe it was
part of my temperament to begin with is
like
if you put off fights they don't get
better not usually they usually get
worse and maybe you think well i'll be
in better position later and you might
be but probably you won't
and so that notion that it's not a good
time fair enough you know i hate
conflict i really hate it i'm not built
for it temperamentally
but i've learned
through painful experience i would say
and not least as a clinician that
when
when you see the elephant's trunk under
the rug you can infer the rest of the
elephant and
it's going to get bigger as you feed it
with your stupidity and your withdrawal
and and you let
whatever it's feeding on continue
and it's extremely dangerous you see you
see this reflected in in ancient
mythology actually quite quite nicely in
many in many situations you see that
this in the mesopotamian creation myth
where a dragon grows in the background
essentially that threatens to swamp
everything and
and that's eventually defeated by a
great you know
marduk as it turns out this is a very
old idea that little things left
grow in the dark and get big and so it's
not really a very good reason and
especially if your conscience is bugging
you because it's something that looks
into the future and says well this is
kind of small at the moment but
but yeah but
yeah
no that's right and actually go on james
well i'll just say yeah i remember uh
reading that that there's a kind of
babylonian creation myth i think isn't
it um but but that sense of things just
growing uh with a kind of gathering a
momentum of their own is is something
that we've we've experienced a lot of i
think it's there's there's been some
work on this in sociology i think they
call it the spiral of silence
um
is it i can't remember elizabeth neumann
or noel neumann and
the basic idea is that is the
fear of isolation
uh social isolation ostracism is is is
like a huge motivating factor in a
person's behavior and
yeah well there's two great fears right
that's one is is being is being uh
isolated and thrown out of the group
because then you die and the other is
biological catastrophe those are the two
big classes of fears that you see as a
clinician
right so that's the animating idea and
then the spiral starts you know the
monster starts to grow when
some people notice that their opinions
are are spreading fast
and that gives them a kind of confidence
to double down and express themselves
more confidently and then on the other
hand people who disagree with those
opinions see that their view is gaining
less traction
and they stay silent because of the fear
of social isolation and then they get
weaker
they get weaker and of course
yeah
and a lot of these people
they're gorgeous
well i was just going to say that you
know social media and those sorts of
things that obviously all the network
effects from that accelerates that um
and so it and what happens is that
people just get very bad at judging what
the real spread of opinion is in in a
social environment
and then it's a kind of so it's a
dynamic process it's a spiral and so you
get a spiral to the point where
what is a confident minority but
minority position becomes this
completely unassailable
orthodoxy
um
and and i think that's one reason why in
the case of what was started to happen
in cambridge in in the summer of uh 2020
and leading up to the vote in in
december is is is that uh what what we
saw was that although there was
reluctance deep reluctance among
colleagues who struggled to get more
than 25 votes to to sign in public the
araf's amendments
when it came to the vote
uh
which crucially operated by a secret
ballot so you were allowed to measure
opinion
but with people voting by people voting
from within the closet as it were
uh and as soon as that that mechanism
was allowed to operate you suddenly the
spiral of silence just as it were the
the
monster explodes
right so that's really interesting
procedurally as well because these sorts
of positive feedback loop phenomena and
you see those in in clinical therapy too
so for example when people start to get
depressed then they withdraw and and
they stop
socializing say and they stop engaging
in their in the activities that bring
them meaning and joy and so that makes
their depression worse and then they're
more likely to to withdraw again and
you know it's probably an example of
something like the pareto principle
operating again right that
things can spiral up very very rapidly
and dominate and they can spiral down
very it's non-linear on both ends and
and
there's some truth to that that kind of
process that underlies all sorts of
phenomena so that secret ballot issue
that's really relevant for bringing
something like this to a halt
yeah i mean i think yeah
go go go ahead okay no it's going to say
one i mean one one part of that
isolation process also i think i mean i
is is
certain kinds of social interactions or
professional interactions and what i
mean is the experience of being in
meetings for instance departmental
meetings or college meetings where
probably a lot of people you there'll be
some mad or insane proposal i know to
say we're going to remove all pronouns
from our policy or we're going to have
this this change of the syllabus or
whatever and
everybody or maybe most people in the
room
were thinking this is nonsense but i'm
not going to say it's nonsense and they
left the meeting thinking they were the
only person who thought it was
because nobody spoke out and the thing
was not decided by a secret ballot if it
had been decided by a secret ballot as
was the case as james says in december
suddenly you had thousands of people
realizing that they weren't alone
it's also possible that the objections
so imagine those objections manifest
themselves in people's imagination but
they're not hooked so tightly to the
whole to a whole ideological network as
the proposal is and so in some sense
people don't have the right words at
hand immediately you know the pronoun
thing is a good indication because
well justify your use of he and she it's
like well i don't know how to do that
exactly you know that's what everyone
does we've done that forever and and
that's my justification it's like well
it's pretty weak compared to that whole
ideology that's coming at you and and
those people who are so committed
they're they're often pretty verbal
they're pretty well able to articulate
that ideology and quite forcefully and
they're emotionally committed to it and
so
that's also a structural problem
and they have devices so for instance if
you think about the way i found the way
these people use terms like not only
welfare but also harm you know the idea
that words do harm to people um which
has a lot of currency now in britain and
is chilling
is based on an absurdly inflated
conception of harm but when you're in
the middle of a discussion you know it's
also related to another cognitive
problem which is one of the things i
often did as a therapist when someone
told me they were afraid of something
doing something is i said well that's
because you're not afraid enough of not
doing it
because that the doing produces this
harm let's say
and you can be afraid of that but the
not doing is sort of invisible and that
that has something to do with decision
making in uncertainty by the way and so
i used to get people to flesh out
what would happen if they didn't do the
thing they were afraid of and then they
thought oh i see there's real risk both
ways and now i get to pick my risk and
this harm issue is the same thing
because you could say well sometimes
words do do harm there's no doubt about
that and maybe that's it's unfair to
conflate that with something like
physical violence although you could
have a discussion about that but the the
the question that isn't being asked then
is well what harm does your attempt to
shut down what words you regard as
harmful
what's that likely to produce for harm
well none it's like oh really so you
haven't thought that part of it through
at all and you're gonna be the arbiter
of what's harmful and what's not and
there's no danger in that either is
there so
that's a good way to
deal with that sort of thing i agree of
course another thing that the a lot of
the time people people don't see is they
think you know we can impose on people's
speech we can tell them how to behave
various ways but they don't think that
that's an instrument that could be
abused in all sorts of ways so if you
mandate speech on one thing one day it's
going to be mandated on other things the
next day and in general i think with any
form of coercive coercive principle you
need to think what's going to happen in
the hands of somebody wicked and you
know tyrannical that's how we should
think about about these things um not
only in university but in politics more
generally
typical right-wing claptrap
well that's kind of an interesting thing
right because one one thing that
conservative thinking does always is say
yeah but
it's like well you're putting this
forward for the good and fair enough you
know and it's based on compassion and
that's actually a virtue although it is
by no means the only virtue and
sometimes it's a vice but why are you so
sure that this will only do the thing
you think it will do and nothing else
and that you're wise enough to make that
change right in something that's sort of
working already
so
part part of the problem might be that i
think it's a sort of a glitch within
liberalism when you think back to to
mill's idea the famous no harm principle
which for many many years operated as a
very very good
basic rule for governing social
interaction but you can understand the
temptation of trying to fold under the
notion of harm or violence i think it's
the australian psychologist nick haslam
calls this concept creed you can see
that you see the sort of the power that
comes from leveraging these concepts
particularly when an institution is
caught in the headlights of a of a
twitter marble or whatever it might be
uh that there's such a threat to the
heart you know there's harm or threats
of harm or violence to the person which
are
in the end i mean i think i take your
point jordan there may well be certain
situations in which uh use of speech can
be thought of as as in inflicting harm
but that is something that society and
and and the legislature in that society
needs to deliberate upon and and decide
and and you know we all accept that
freedom of speech is not uh is not an
unqualified right and and indeed
academic freedom has has uh proper
parameters imposed uh as well um so well
we could also be grown up and say that
it's it's dangerous but necessary
it's dangerous but necessary
i think the danger comes in when what
counts as harm is being subjectively
determined
and so this notion that that's that
started to uh gather steam in the last
few years this idea of a microaggression
which
in effect is is is an aggression or a
claim that harm has been inflicted on a
person that that is subjectively
determined
that is to say it's it's in principle
not an offense that could be
uh
explored in any kind of forensic context
by by by a jury or a judge that is to
say the only evidence that count of the
harm that could possibly count
is the subject saying you've hurt me
and the and so the danger of the
language that that arif was was uh
protesting against the rest of the
identitarian respect language is that it
effectively conferred a veto
on the most psychologically fragile
person
on in in the university
uh and who could simply say and we would
not there would be no way of
establishing whether or not they that
they were sincere with that they'd have
to be just simply taking it face value
that this person the the invitation to
this speaker troubles me upsets me does
does me harm yeah well that's
interesting too like imagine you take
that
hypothetical
sensitive person it might not be in
their best interests
to actually grant them that sort of veto
power because one of the things you do
with someone who's really depressed or
anxious is actually especially if you're
working as a cognitive behaviorist let's
say is you get them to look at the
thoughts that are upsetting them and
maybe modify the ones that are making
them
um
sensitive beyond what is good for them
in in and that's also to some degree
judged subjectively by them and so it
isn't necessarily the case that
protecting people in that manner and
giving them that sort of power is
actually in their best interest so
it reminds me of that um insight of
jonathan hyde and greg lukianov in there
i think it's their 2017 atlantic article
that became the coddling of the american
mind where one of the three principles i
think jonathan isolates is um
is a sort of inversion of the
nietzschean idea that you know um uh
what what doesn't kill you makes you
weaker um that is to say
anything that that you know the sort of
harm or or or violence that that sort of
any kind of threat is it doesn't have
it's not something that can toughen you
up it's not an opportunity to try and um
strengthen your character or to develop
resilience i know that i think this is
something you've touched on that's also
a huge part of what you that's also a
huge part of what universities are doing
for
their students if you think about it
psychologically so we could talk about
people who are hypersensitive to anxiety
and depression let's say they're higher
in neuroticism well one of the things
you want to do when you get educated is
arm yourself with defenses
and i mean practical defenses both
ideational so the way you think and the
way you act against that kind of
onslaught and education can really do
that right because you're quicker on
your feet and you you know more and and
and also if you're trying to reduce
someone's anxiety and depression and
they're temperamentally tilted that way
what you actually do is gradually expose
them to the things that they're afraid
of you don't you don't protect them more
and more and more because that actually
makes that positive
spiral descent into depression and
anxiety worse so the fact the idea that
you should remove everything that might
threaten someone's identity
and you should make that a
university-wide policy is actually
exactly the opposite of what you should
do speaking clinically if you're trying
to help people become more resilient
this is a serious issue and and
well obviously this is all serious
but the fact the fact is the
universities in the uk are to some
extent going in the opposite direction
so they do have as james points out this
category of what's called
microaggressions and these are things
which can even be a matter of
disciplinary action if you're reporting
for it when you say at nyu there's
posters all over the place like in the
bathrooms for example encouraging people
to report such things to the appropriate
you know well-paid bureaucratic
authorities well cambridge tried to
introduce a system where you could
report you could report these things
anonymously so not confidentially
anonymously nobody knows who made the
report so it's like he's germany the
report comes in and then somebody could
in principle be disciplined for it yeah
no one would ever be able to use that no
you couldn't imagine that um so as you
say you know if if making fun of
someone's religion for instance is
something i can't do you know that's a
kind of challenge which might upset them
um and as you say part of the point of
words is to some extent that they do
some harm they're meant to be upsetting
they're meant to shake your views about
things you know if the conversations you
have at university you know never upset
you never make you feel a little bit
less confident never make you make you
perhaps even make you cry sometimes
university isn't doing its job
yeah
i couldn't agree more and in fact the
anonymous reporting tool mechanism that
is accompanied with these long shopping
lists of microaggressions effectively uh
where as you said it's happening at nyu
jordan that students and staff are
encouraged effectively to to to police
each other and to censor each other it
was a very disturbing development i mean
uh thankfully it is
the story of good positive developments
in cambridge is that when the university
rolled out this uh i think it was called
change the culture campaign that back in
may that it spent a couple of years
working on the
the backlash i think was ah
intense enough among senior colleagues
to for for for stephen toot the vice
chancellor to to uh in the in the end
take it down and and admit that it had
been put up in error and as actually as
far as uh
sorry as he said as i recall
he he wasn't aware that it had gone up
but he wasn't aware of the
microaggressions uh uh component but but
this is a problem throughout the uk i
mean it turned out that the company is a
sort of tech startup called culture
shift
which uh
which rolled it out in cambridge but
there there i think there are 50 or 60
other universities in the uk that have a
system of of this kind
you know there's no there's no such
thing as a joke that isn't a
microaggression
right jokes aren't funny unless they're
microaggressions especially witty jokes
and so so you know that's why i'm so
concerned when i see comedians getting
stopped because they're bellwethers for
this sort of thing
and if you can't take a joke i mean well
i was talking with my wife and some
friends about the way working-class men
sort of test each other out and a huge
part of that is this throwing back and
forth of
microaggressions sometimes they're not
so micro right it's like let's see if i
can get under your skin
can you take a joke can you lower your
ego you know or do you get too upset are
you too narcissistic are you too
arrogant can we rely on you in a crunch
or even a little crunch like can you
cooperate can you subordinate your needs
to the group now and then or you
narcissist all that's played out with
aggressive humor and putting a clamp on
that is a catastrophe plus it's not
funny anymore like you know we need some
we need some humor i think there are
there are different subcultures where
you get different kind of equilibria
here so there are some cultures like as
you say you know in barracks for
instance um also in roman times you know
hume describes you know roman b as a
human says roman people were very rude
to each other from what we know of their
conversations compared to even
high and low ranking people they were
not afraid to be rude to each other and
make fun of each other compared to
how we are in our society now other ones
military military environments i think
are like that some environments i was in
when i was a child you know these are
these are equilibria that societies can
end up in and there are other equilibria
which are much more covering and much
much more timid and it seems the fear is
as you say we're going to end up in one
of those where where yeah and those are
authorities authoritarian you know one
of the things i learned as a studying
psychoanalytic thought mostly was the
notion of compassion as devouring
an excess of compassion is a vice and it
becomes totalitarian and no one that i
know of yet has had a serious
conversation about female
totalitarianism and that's a
conversation long overdue because
females are now part and parcel of the
general political culture in a way they
haven't been in many societies for a
very long time and so
this totalitarianism of compassion is no
joke
you know it was freud's primary concern
that's the eatable mother fundamentally
the word that the expression i've heard
used in a lot of places for this is what
people call soft totalitarianism so it's
not it's not it's totally totally
terrorism it's not the jackfruit or the
or the prison you know it's the smiley
emoji and they're you know not hurting
people's feelings um but the result is
the same when it comes to free speech
and argument and the truth um uh uh and
just having rational discourse because
so much of it is suppressed so that's
what we're fearing but as james says you
know there are reasons for hope when you
compare
so as james was talking about the
microaggressions episode in cambridge
you know the backlash against that i
mean i don't know what you think jesus
my impression was the backlash against
that was much more quick in public than
it was against the the um
the free speech policy a year and a bit
before so that's right so you might open
the door
the the the culture to some extent seems
to be improving a bit people seem a bit
more confident to speak out james i
don't know if that's your case yeah i
mean i think you're right i mean i think
on the one hand it was it was
distressing after the scale of the vote
and the uh the clarity with which the
views of the majority of staff of the
majority of those voted and i can't
remember what the margins were about 85
percent voted for the tolerance language
over the respect language
it was
depressing that you know barely six
months later this campaign has rolled
out that just seemed to be
antithetical in every conceivable
respect to what that to to to to ha to
the views that were expressed at the
ballot box in in december but as arab
said that the sort of grou the grass
roots um
resistance to it was was much faster um
i mean it's true i think that and this
might have been to some extent
true of of the vote itself but that
one different one big difference from
two or three years ago with your the
recision of your invitation jordan is
the
the um the extramural support that we've
had outside the universities so the
public awareness public attention and
public concern taxpayer concern
uh has been much more focused on on the
problem of the crisis of the perceived
crisis of the university and so we there
was quite a lot of press coverage i
remember around about you know end of
may beginning of june when this was
happening and i think that must have put
up put a lot of pressure on and and
brought about immediate ins an immediate
and dramatic institutional response that
i don't know what i have think but i
think would have been very very hard to
achieve just internally by writing
letters and and and complaining using
sort of ordinary procedures
um so so i think that that would have
that that played a big role and
i think people are starting to
understand to some degree that these
obscure goings-on in universities
uh
move downstream with incredible rapidity
when i first made that observation not
that i was the first to do it
that you should that the general public
should be concerned about these strange
academic ideas it seemed like i was
overreacting but you know everyone's
learned in some sense in that since then
what do they say politics is downstream
from culture and cultures generated in
the universities for better or worse and
so
what happens on campus doesn't stay on
campus yes exactly unlike las vegas
right and i wanted to clear something up
because earlier you pointed to the
utility of anonymity in a vote right but
then you
criticized anonymous reporting and so i
just want i want to clear that up so
it's way different because anonymous
reporting is one person and that can
easily be someone who's quite malevolent
and if you don't think people like that
exist it's just because you're naive
they can use that as an unbelievably
powerful weapon to to take down in a
very painful way anyone they want
whereas if it's a vote and we should
talk about the vote because my
understanding is that thousands of
people voted on this policy so who were
those thousands of people and how did
that come about
well it was it was i mean you're quite
right about the distinction first of all
um i mean the point about anonymous
reported is that you somehow report
something anonymously you can't come
back to them to check their evidence you
know the person who's been accused can't
you can't even face their accuser so
there's there's no possibility of due
process um
with the anonymous voting so the turnout
was about it's about 1500 people so it's
about 30 which doesn't seem that high
but actually it was it was very high by
historical standards so i've been
looking back over the last three or four
decades and so i couldn't find one where
there was such a high turnout and such a
decisive margin actually so it was a big
it was a big um uh result especially
given that it was taking place during
the lockdown it was taking place
at the height of the pandemic
um so the people who were voting they
were all academics cambridge is unusual
in british academia and maybe unusual in
western academia more generally in that
it and oxford are both self-governing
and what that means is that it's the
supreme body that decides what it does
is the sort of
main body of senior academics so all
lecturers professors and so on
um and there's about 7000 of those those
that's called regent house and that has
supreme authority now there is an
executive body called the council which
handles most day-to-day business
and the council often makes proposals on
which there is no vote in this it
doesn't propose a vote and one of the
telling things is that the council put
forward this this proposal which was
on a matter of fundamental value i can't
think of anything of more importance to
a university than its view on freedom of
speech
it put forward this change it did not
offer a vote when i made my objections
it did not offer a vote when i made my
objections it didn't negotiate it didn't
say well i can see the point of this
maybe we should have a wider
consultation there's no attempt at
consultation no attempt to vote it just
tried to push it through um
so the difficulty wasn't getting a vote
in the first place once we got a vote um
as it turned out um
things the things worked well uh but the
difficulty was in getting the vote and
the vote was was conducted by by senior
academics so people like me james you if
you've been in cambridge i can't imagine
that toronto is being is run like that i
don't know if any american universities
or north american
universities have run like that but
cambridge and oxford are lucky in that
they have that system of governments
i i received quite a few messages after
the vote and i think probably arif did
too from from colleagues around the
country and and actually around the
world who was sort of expressing a kind
of
envy that they didn't have that sort of
quasi-parliamentary mechanism which you
know it's a clunky tool it took arab and
those supporting him a very long time to
to kind of get it all going and and to
and to challenge the university's
decisions but it did work
it gives the faculty final say and not
the pure and not the administration and
that's really something
yeah yeah it's important i mean it's not
quite as simple as that because there
are some administrators who can vote as
well but they all they kind of tend to
vote the same way i would imagine but it
does give us to say and i want to say
again um you know none of it would have
been possible without james as well he
played a massive role in getting the
support you know giving it public
support and helping with publicity and
so on um so he was brilliant um i do
want to add we got i mean i got messages
on phil james too not just from from
academics but from members of the public
as well um
who was sort of relieved that an
important british institution like
cambridge was actually standing up for
for basic values because this is not an
abstract academic matter and it's not
even intellectually very difficult thing
to see you know the arguments were not
intellectually obscure or difficult or
required any great intelligence you know
it was really simple matters of basic
principle um
so i think it would have been it would
have been a disaster i think if
cambridge had you know had not supported
this i wanted to point out something
else to clarify something that you just
said when we were talking about
anonymous reporting and def
differentiating that from anonymous
voting
you said well this anonymous reporting
circumvents due process and he didn't
say that very loud and we just went on
it's like no no we're going to say that
again
this anonymous reporting circumvents due
process it's like what the hell is up
with you guys you're doing an end run
around due process who the hell do you
think you are exactly
due process it's like god how long has
english common law been working out due
process
yeah it is a basic principle of english
common law and it's a basic principle of
natural justice that you know the
identity of the of your accuser and you
know the grounds on which he's making
the accusation
uh and these mechanisms that are
introduced often without any kind of
scrutiny at all um are cut completely
against that principle yeah and they're
designed to
so because with that sort of thing
there's you know i always prefer to to
presume ignorance and not malevolence
but when something like that happens
there's something damn ugly going on way
down at the bottom
so what's worrying is that it's across
as james was saying it isn't just in
cambridge where we managed to we managed
to stop it this this firm which appears
to be running this this platform this
kind of snitching portal or stasi portal
um for making anonymous denunciations
has been bought by about 50 or 60
universities across the country um i
remember someone saying to me when i was
protesting against it in cambridge they
said well look most universities in
england have got it why you know why are
you so bothered whether we we get it is
there is a perfectly normal acceptable
thing that we should we should as you
say oh good so now we have an automated
system in place in 60 universities in
the uk to circumvent due process
to be fair to be fair i think some of
them are ones where
where you could only the only thing you
can submit anonymously is a report on
which no formal action is taken so you
just take some boxes and nothing happens
but there are some where it goes further
so so it's terrifying that we're at that
stage in universities in all places yeah
yeah there was a report done last
december by civitas which is sort of
right-leaning think-tank with a very
very good report on the state of
academic freedom in the uk and i think
they found
you have a look 83 out of 140 you know
uk universities were found to have some
kind of anonymous
reporting systems so it's it's it's very
very widespread um and uh yeah and it
just it's it's a huge issue uh very very
concerning and and i think that as arif
says i mean a lot of it is may well be
well-intentioned um but i think the
point is that it starts off processes
and procedures disciplinary procedures
where
you know the end result may not be
anything at all it may just be a few
weeks of um having to go
you know
see the chair of your faculty you'll go
to see some committee or you'll have to
pay trips to hr but as a colleague of
ours says um you know if the process is
the punishment
yeah exactly there's nothing trivial
about any of that that's awful when that
happens to someone it's so awful it just
it just does still
taste tall
yeah and it puts a shadow on them
right right
and it has a chilling effect as well
what do you see happen to one person in
your department or your university you
know you just watch yourself you don't
say things like that
you know again or yourself you know what
you publish what you say in meetings
what you say to students you just become
more and more careful and another thing
i think is that is that i mean tophill
talks about this quite well which is the
one way to terrorize people is not to
not to control them in big things but to
control them in little things so that
tyranny becomes a habit conformity
becomes a habit every time you say
something little you know some small
interactions you're constantly looking
over your shoulder
worrying whether to say this or not that
thompson it is the most efficient way to
turn people into sheep oh it's also sort
of in some sense the ultimate reach of
totalitarianism because your life is
made out of small things you know big
things are rare and seldom and so having
to watch that well i have to say to
watch your sense of humor for example
you know and fair enough you can you can
cross the line and an astute person
reads the crowd properly and but you see
great comedians man they're right on
that edge right they're right at the
point where they shouldn't be saying
what they're saying well some of them
far past that line on purpose you know
but everyone knows
but
but to chill that is to take almost all
the fun the dynamic fun out of social
interactions that spirit that's that's a
free spirit and that makes all that
partly what makes life worth living it's
terrible that these things are happening
and it's more terrible that the
universities are doing it
how how shameful so okay so of this
about how many of the seven thousand
eligible people voted do you do you know
so it was about thirty percent of them
um
that was that was a high turnout
historically very high turnout um
and of those uh it was as james says
about 85 was in favor of of my
amendments um it varied depending on the
amendment so one of the amendments was
that was the one which was most popular
was was in favor of respect replacing
the language of respect with the much
more neutral and i think liberal
language of tolerance um
the other amendments were essentially
saying that the university couldn't stop
speaker events unless they were illegal
and that's a good that's a good rule
and then another amendment was was
incorporating some of the language of
the chicago principles which i think is
a good example a good sort of standard
to replace this language which was
saying the university could stop things
whenever it wanted and it would pay
attention to the welfare of students and
the public when people were giving
giving talks so now we've got a policy
where if you've been invited you can't
be disinvited um and it doesn't matter
unless you're doing something illegal
right and you're legal you can't be
disappointed um
so it's been a change um and indeed it
was actually the people who first
celebrated it were the radical feminists
so so it was actually surprising
amongst my allies you know they were
christians and they were also radical
feminists you know because those are
both different sides who felt for
various reasons and hard scientists as
well they too it was the hard scientists
radical feminists um lawyers um
christians um they were all for various
reasons felt that their speech had been
curtailed or was being limited and it
was the feminists who celebrated it
first so sophie that that very brave
student that we talked about organized
what she called re-platforming events
where she invited a number of of
you know very controversial speakers
kathleen stock for instance and others
to come and give talks in cambridge um
about time
is that girl still around that young
woman is she still around cambridge i'm
not in touch with her i believe she
graduated from the first class degree
last summer um
uh
invited her to the talk
yeah yeah um i'm sure we could that
would be positive um
uh but uh so there were some very brave
people amongst the feminists and amongst
these other groups um and that was that
was the first thing that happened
afterwards and then now we've had
another thing which is your invitation
and we're hoping to
and not only that i think in some ways
more importantly the culture is i hope
changing day-to-day interactions are
changing people are more willing to
speak out at meetings i want to try and
get through changes whereby
there is you know secret voting happens
at all meetings at all levels not just
at these big levels yeah well one of the
things we're facing
all of us as a potential danger is that
although in the west in some ways we've
got our large-scale uppermost political
institutions tilted quite hard against
totalitarianism it seems to be creeping
into mid-level bureaucracies continually
right and there it's a lot harder to
fight
it's harder to get people interested
it's more invisible
all of that
what do you think i'd be interested what
your your view and experience is because
my my impression has been of of the sort
of mid and high level bureaucracy in my
university for instance is that they're
not they're not really ideological
they're not committed to this there's
some sort of
mad hard left ideology or any of that
really they're just they just you know
they want to respond to concerns from
students and others they've been given a
misleading impression that a lot of
people have these concerns there are
also commercial concerns because of
course universities charge fees now and
they have to care about attracting
students and so on and so they're just
sort of doing what's you know they're
taking the path of least resistance
well i think part of what's happened is
that
well hr is is
punching way above its weight you know
it was bottom of the totem pole in
corporations for years and also in
institutions like universities and then
it latched on to this diversity
inclusivity and equity mantra and there
is power in that man and so i would say
yes to everything you said except
for that exception and
the watching corporations jump on this
is really quite comical in some sense
because
what that is all allied with is not
something that has capitalism as its
central interest let's put it that way
so
yeah
you end up
yeah no i mean i i think that's
absolutely right so that there are as
arif says the sort of mid-level
administration is typically not
particularly ideology ideologically
driven but as we were discussing earlier
all it takes is sort of two two or three
dead dedicated
activists to cause a lot of trouble and
what's happening now in the kind of
administrative landscape of a lot of
these institutions corporations
universities and
and other sectors as well is that you've
effectively got people whose job it is
to deliver on equality diversity and and
and inclusion initiatives that is to say
that's their standing job that's their
profession and so is it where the
revolution can never come to an end
right you can never reach the sunlit
uplands there's always got to be the
next
there's always got to be the the the
next phobia to confront uh and so it's
kind of true or you lose your jaw or
your job disappears yes or you make
yourself redundant um and and so that
the kind of structural problems there
and kind of ratchet effects that are
very very very difficult to to to to
address
um
what do you think um one way to think
about addressing that might be to
introduce rapture effects in the other
direction so that you know you can have
a sort of free speech bureaucracy um
and you can have you know we have
legislation in this country for instance
which is trying to try to strengthen the
duty or the strength of the the redress
for breaking the duty to promote freedom
of speech um and it could be that that
gives rise to sort of internal
bureaucracies and people will start
thinking well people who would have
thought i could make a career out of
promoting equality and diversity might
start thinking
[Music]
you